What did Communists use to light their houses
before candles?
Electricity.
I asked my North Korean friend how things
been going there.
He said "I can't complain."
Yeah.
Why did the Libertarian quit his job at the
Italian car factory?
Because he hated fiat.
Fiat!
How do you know Arlington National Cemetery
is popular?
I don't know, how?
Because people are dying to get in there.
During, all the foreign wars, without congressional
authorization.
They die overseas and then the body is shipped
back home.
Yeah, no I get the mechanics of it...
And then the families come and visit the graves,
and it's pretty crowded.
I am not sure that joke works.
Yeah well neither does nation building but
people keep trying it.
Okay.
Knock knock-
Get a warrant?
Get a warrant.
Oh no wait I got one:
You start though, say 'who's there.'
No, with a knock knock joke you start with
knock knock.
This is a no knock knock knock joke.
Like a no knock raid but it's a knock knock
joke.
Okay, who's there?
Police, we shot your dog.
Oops, sorry wrong house.
What's the difference between Trump, Obama
and a claustrophobic Eskimo?
There's lots of differences.
Okay well, for this joke, only the Eskimo doesn't
want to get Snowden.
Snowed-in.
Why did the Afghani bride get cold feet?
Why?
Because her legs were blown off in an American
drone strike.
Extra-judicial, again, without congressional
oversight, or authorization.
Why did police take a three year old into
custody?
Was he unarmed and black?
No?
He was resisting a rest!
Right, that makes sense, they just shoot the
black kids.
Austin.
How can you disappoint a Libertarian with
only one Leppo?
What is Aleppo?
God damn.
Just like that.